you heard tony dungy talking about the
early season schedule for the houston
texans they've got five playoff teams in
their first seven games we're going to
play a little game of would you rather
chris and we're going to start with this
would you rather have the texans first
half schedule or the bears second half
schedule they've got seven playoff teams
in the final nine games so would you
rather load up with that gauntlet of
playoff teams early or late what's your
preference
well i'd rather do a deal with it late i
mean i would rather give myself
especially you know with these two teams
in this scenario you know first off the
houston texans hey they got some
moving parts on their team they've
changed around a little bit so to have
that schedule early on in the season and
as you know you know hey i put a lot of
uh
you know a lot of credit into the early
season or what do i want to say a lot of
eggs into the one basket in the early
year you know teams still believe the
teams that were playoff teams last year
still think oh worst playoff team this
year we're gonna make a super bowl run
but that houston texan schedule is it's
brutal early on to where it could throw
your whole season around if you just hey
you mess up here or dominate one game
and have a few end of the game mistakes
all of a sudden you look up and you go
man we're one in four and we're gonna
have to fight for our life the bears you
know when it comes to that scenario hey
they get a chance to kind of get their
feet underneath them and okay let's get
playing our best football by the time we
start to get into the meat and potatoes
of the rams and the saints and the
titans and the vikings and that part of
the schedule not to say any of the teams
they play early on are like easy but
i do think i would rather have it that
way than what the houston texans got as
far as just being thrown into the fire
right from week one and being been in
some tough road there for the first five
weeks
and look there's a lot of reasons to
want the early games to be easier than
the later games look at the jets last
year the jets never got a chance to get
things rolling it didn't help that their
starting quarterback had mono but you go
one in seven just like the falcons one
and seven and then people forget that
you go six and two and here's the other
side of it we gotta move on to the next
one but yeah if you're a coach that's in
any type of trouble that's in any type
of danger
you want the hard games later you want
to get off to a good start
because you don't get off to a good
start you're gone during the season you
get off to a good start you go five and
two right six and two six and three and
you have it fall apart a little bit down
the stretch it's easier to overcome that
than it is to overcome starting off one
and seven for example and last year we
thought dan quinn the falcons coach at
one and seven going into the bye week
was done and gone and he got lucky he
wasn't all right would you rather face
the chiefs tough start or the 49ers
difficult middle stretch for the second
straight year the 49ers have another
group of games where we're going to say
hey if they get through that they can do
anything they got through it last year
would you rather come out of the gates
as the defending super bowl champions
with tough challenges or would you
rather be that super bowl runner-up with
a tough slate of games in the middle of
the year chris
yeah well this is a tough one and again
you know i mean normally i would prefer
here it's almost like i like both of
these schedules a little bit and i'm
going to explain this i mean normally i
would prefer the 49ers type of schedule
yes i mean of course hey they're playing
the cardinals the jets the giants right
off the bat those are three teams that
we know the san francisco 49ers are
better than so you know again even if
you're not playing your best football
there's a good chance you can come out
of those games and be oh we're two and
one oh we're three and oh we haven't
even played good yet
i will say though you know
that kansas city chiefs their schedule i
i don't know how to
say this best what i want to say mike is
this if you're if there's one team that
i think
sir is served best by having a tough
early season schedule i think it's the
kansas city chiefs i think it's one of
the few teams in football that actually
favors them and here's my reason why
andy reid as we know he's famous for bye
week right after the bye week early
season trickery whoa andy read this off
season he's been in the lab with his pen
in the pad and he's trying to get this
damn offense off right sorry that was a
dr dre line i just couldn't help it but
either way he's gonna have some new
tricks and and new schemes and things
like that to where we've seen them be a
handful early in the season and we saw
last year teams start to catch on to
their offense in the middle of the year
halfway at the end of the year i think
the chiefs are one of those teams where
i look at and go they can overwhelm
teams early in the year you know
defenses are still kind of getting their
feet underneath them and all of a sudden
it's like whoa tyree kill mahomes wow
whoa you know and i just feel like if
there's one team in football that
benefits early on in the year from
having really tough schedule it's kansas
city because i feel like their explosive
firepower and their new plays and and
new things they do in the system could
catch a team off guard
let me give you another angle here two
deaks if there's any complacency
whatsoever that affects the kansas city
chiefs by virtue that's a great angle
super bowl having great teams right out
of the gates you don't have time to rest
on your laurels you don't have time to
just show up and coast and win you got
to get right back at it right out of the
gates and that makes it easier for andy
reid to get the attention of his players
and get them focused on getting off to a
great start and and uh you know avoiding
a one and three or a two and two
commencement to the scene that's a tough
one like what would you what did you
think there i mean i know i normally
would always go with the 49ers and i'd
rather have the tough middle stretch but
i do feel like the with the chiefs it's
a little different
if i'm the defending champions i i want
i want them to come at me come at me now
let's go let's come out earlier because
because i think it does help wake you up
and it does help avoid that sense of ah
this is going to be easy there's no this
is going to be easy if you're the chiefs
now that you have your schedule and that
may get the players even more focused
not that there was any risk that these
chiefs wouldn't be but we've seen it
before it's a human dynamic you climb to
the top of the mountain you go back to
the bottom and what are you going to do
or climb the mountain we just climbed
you got to find creative ways to get
guys inspired to go through the grind
and the fight week after week to go do
the thing they just did all right uh
would you rather face the patriots
tougher schedule in an easier division
or the buccaneers easier schedule
in a more challenging division chris
well i mean first off i just want to
challenge that question are we sure that
that's the easier division i mean i you
know i know tom brady left saints
the saints and keep naming the playoffs
the buccaneers the same the falcons the
falcons
the falcons i know i'm the panda those
have potential
well i know but is it are we just
they're definitely because i look at
last year's collective record and the
afc east was better than the nfc south
and they had two playoff teams so i want
to be like well i don't like the
question right off the bat by t pete dim
a little lighter lettuce okay but i
think you know ultimately what would i
rather have in this year
uh i'd probably rather have the tampa
bay buccaneer scenario yeah it's very
close as far as what division is better
i i i'm just giving pete a hard time
there but that new england schedule is
just absolutely brutal and not to say
tampa bay's is easy but they have some
things going their way as far as some
tough teams they're playing at home uh
you know even the early start of the
season yes i know the saints is tough
but the panthers the broncos are a team
that's still you know figuring
themselves out and on the rise dangerous
nonetheless i think tampa bay schedule
is is far now i don't want to say far
easier but but man the new england
schedule is brutal i mean to me i look
at the new england schedule and think
it's the toughest in football and it has
like two or three stretches where i just
go wow what a year for jared sidham to
take over the reins here because this
will not be easy
all right give me the easier schedule
because i'm not just competing in my
division now with three wild card berths
i'm competing with the other teams in
the other divisions in my conference
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports